وانا احييكم من جديد لا تزال السلطات
الاوكرانيه تعمل على معرفه ملابسات حادثه
تحطم الطائره المروحيه التي تسببت في سقوط
عشرات القتل والمصابين الحادث ادى لمقتل
ثلاثه من ابرز قيادات الداخليه الاوكرانيه
ومسؤولينا عسكريين كبار وهم وزير الداخليه
ونائب وزير الداخليه وسكرتيره الدوله في
وزاره الشؤون الداخليه سقطت المروحيه
التابعه لجهاز الدوله قرب حضانه مليئه
بالاطفال خارج المدينه كيف اثناء اداء
مهمه عسكريه
فوق مدينه بوفاري الاوكرانيه الواقعه شمال
شرق العاصمه الاكرانيه وهنا تطرح تساؤلات
كثيره عن سبب سقوط هذه المروحيه التي كانت
تقل تسعه من ابرز القيادات الاوكرانيه بين
من يرى انه حادث عربي نتيجه سبب فني وبين
من يرى انه عمليه اختلال قد يكون وراءها
روسيا او طرف ثالث كما وصفه مراقبون وفاه
وزير الداخليه الاوكرانيه سوف تلقي
بظلالها على تطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
مع خساره كاف وزيرا مختصه في مهام حيويه
من بينها اداره الشرطه خلال الحرب
[موسيقى]
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفي
دار الخبير في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا بكم
من ابو ظبي
اهلا بكم
من موسكو معك استاذ دويدار استاذ دويدار
الباص الغاز فكره ان يكون هذا الحادث
نتيجه قدريه او عرضيه ووجهها وبدات
الاصوات تواجه الاتهامات روسيا هل يمكن ان
تكون روسيا او ان تقف وراء هذا الحادث
كل شيء ورد لكن
لا اعتقد ان اييي على يعني الدوله الروسيه
بقدراتها ان
تبذل ذلك المجهود لي الافتاح
بالقياده للشرطه وزاره الداخليه
الاوكرانيه
لانه دوره نوعا ما محدود
ذلك الوزير ههه
من الذين هم متعاونين
او ما يسمى
متعاونين من قبل الاوكران
حين دخول القوات الروسيه للمناطق
الاوكرانيه
لا اعتقد انه انا برافاريه نعرف بروفاريه
هذا منطقي الشمال الشرقي
لا توجد هناك اي قدرات روسيه لاسقاط تلك
الطائره
لا يوجد احد للتخريبها هذه الطائره
الفرنسيه الى احد يستخدمها في اوروبا
من حيث القدرات التقنيه
والسلامه
الاداء
صحيح تقول حضرتك بانه كل شيء وارد ولكن
بحسب الاشارات قد تستبعد روسيا من وقوفها
وراء هذا الحادث هو فعلا هناك اصوات تحدثت
عن اتهامات لروسيا ولكن الاصوات الاعلى
سيد
اتهمت داخل الاوكراني اتهم الطرفا ثالث
لروسيا هو الذي يقف وراء هذا الحدث ما
رايك
مساء الخير يا مرشدين الكرام مساء الخير
ريم ااا من يتهم الدخل الاوكراني لا يعرف
هذا داخل لان اليوم اي يؤيد الاردنيون
بالنسبه تبوك 90% جميع القرارات واعمال
القياده اللبنانيه فيما يتعلق باداره ضمور
الحاره
لانه بالنسبه
هذا همم
بالنسبه همم
وليست هذه الحادثه الاولى ان صنفنا بعض
الحوادث ذات الصله او التي فيها تشابهات
مثلا صواريخ التي سقطت في بولندا في الاول
كانت التي اتهامات موجهه لروسيا ولكن
اكتشف فيما بعد بان هناك جهه اوكرانيه هي
التي حاولت التحرش او بالخطا بولندا
فالموضوع موضوع نقسمات وارد
من السياسيين الاوكرانيين هم يؤيدون
القياده الاخرانيه يعني بشكل شديد وهذا
يعني واضح كما قلت لان هم يعرفون ان همم
تمزيق وحده اللبنانيين هو الطريق المستقيم
الى الهزيمه واحتلال الاوكراني او اختفاء
اوكراني كدوله مستقله هم يعرفون هذا
يفهمون يعني هذه الفطوره
هل تتفق مع ضيفي بان هناك وحده
اوكرانيه او كما يقول بعض المراقبين هناك
نقاط استفهام على الاقل حتى وان لم تكن
هناك امور مؤكده ولكن نقاط استفهام ثابته
بخصوص امكانيه ان يكون هناك فرع همم ثالث
اسمهم مراقبون في داخل الاوكراني يحاول في
كل مره ان يقوم بحادث او ان همم يؤثر
الوضع اكثر
انا لم افهم ما قال هو صراحه الاحترام له
ربما يفهم السؤال ما هو يتحدث عن ربما
الراي العام
والتكتل امام العقبات التي
امام الشعب الاوكراني لكن لم يتطرق الى اي
شيء
مهم بخصوص السياسه
الاوكرانيه والسياسيه يوم امس ااه سيد
اريستون
لا ادري يعني ماذا سوف يفعل همم ابتداء من
هذا اليوم كان هو البوق الرسمي
للسيد الانسكي في الاعلام
وهو مجرد ذكر انه اه اه حدث في نيبر بتروس
التي الان نيبرو في اوكرانيا تلك العماره
التي دمرت بصاروخ انه كان صاروخ اوكراني
فهمم
نزل عليه كل ما هو سيء من الاوكران في
السياسيين
واعتزل اليوم شاهدنا مشهد مريب للغايه
اسرائيل لان كل
ما يخص الامن
بشركات باداره الاداريين بشركات الاداريين
في الدوله ل- لا يسمح لهم باقتناء مركبات
واحده يكونوا مجموعه واحده في مركبه او
يتعرض لكي لا يتعرض لحادث مثل ما حدث قد
يطيح ب- اطاحه الرئاسه كامله
للمؤسسه او للوحده او للشركه
فهناك تساؤلات بالطبع انا لست من الذين
يقال بانه يمنع ان يتخذ وزير الداخليه
ومعه نائبه ومعه احد المستشارين او احد اا
اصحاب المناصب العليا نفس المروحيه
العسكريه لماذا حدث ذلك
يعني جميع البرتقلات المناسبه السلميه لان
في هذه الظروف والاستثنائيه احيانا يجب ان
طاقه القرارات والاجراءات المناسبه وربما
هم شافوا ان هذا امر مناسب يعني في هذا
الامر
ويستدل في ذلك على بعض
الانشقاقات او على الاقل الاختلافات في
وجهات النظر حينما تكلم احدهم عن الصواريخ
الاخرانيه قلتم بان هذا لا يجوز في هذه
المرحله فاستقال او تم عزله او اعتزل لا
نعلم تفاصيل في الواقعه
قال شيء غلط لان سيد اريستون ابدا ما قال
انه صاروخ الاوكراني الذي سقط على المبدا
في مدينه نيفرون
هو يعني شيء مختلف يعني تماما قال لان
الدفاعات الجويه الاخرانيه يعترضت الصاروخ
الروسي والصاروخ الروسي
كثير من الابرياء المدني
اعترض صاروخا اوكرانيا وعند اعتراضه سقط
ولكن همم كيف هو سقط في الجانب روسي فاكيد
بان هذا الصاروخ كان متوجه الى الحدود
روسيه حتى يعتبر
بروايه حظرتك
لا لا ربما نحن نتحدث عن الحدث يعني
المختلف يعني لان المدينه
[موسيقى]
لا اريد ان يعني لا استطيع ان اذكر شيئا
اكثر من ذلك الى ان بالطبع وزير الداخليه
الذي
حدثت مع الواقعه اليوم هو من مدينه
في تلك المنطقه
ومعروفه ما هو همم
قومي للغايه
همم وحماه واعتقد سند 21 تولى
منصبه بعد وزير الداخليه
فلسياسي البارز الاوكراني
وعد
بمعدات روسيا
فكان يقوم بكل شيء همم ما وعد به لكن انا
يعني استبعد تماما ان تبذل الدوله الروسيه
اي قدرات حتى ليها نطاح به لانه لا يشكل
همم
كتله حتى في ما يحدث الان ااا
ان تستهدفه هو تحدث ظاهره
همم
ان يكون هذا الحادث عرضي واكد او على
الاقل اشارت الى همم مسؤوليه روسيا همم هل
تعتقد بانه اوكرانيا رسميه ستعتمد وجهه
نظر هذه وعلي ستبني اجراءاتها
بكل احترام استاذ ريما انا ما قلت يعني عن
المسؤوليه همم الروسيا في هذا الحدث نحن
اليوم همم نبدا التحقيق في هذا الحدث
المؤلم وهناك ثلاثه اسباب الرئيسيه كما
قلت قال الفني
وانتهاء اوائل الطيران وطبعا همم العمل
تخريبي ولا يمكننا ان نحدد ما هو يعني
السبب الذي
قليل
وانما لمحت همم الى همم
استفاده روسيا من هذه الخطوه
انا لما احكيني لا استفاضه روسيا في تمزيق
وواحده الاوكرانيين وهذا بالضبط ما تريده
تمزيق وحده الالوكهين
والصف اللبنانيين لانها انت عارف يعني
بشكل جيد ان وحده الركرانيين
لهزيمه روسيا وطبعا روسيا ست تبذل جهود
القدس
من الداخل وهي تعمل يعني كل شيء من من
يعني من اجل هذا الهدف الاستراتيجي
بالنسبه
لا يستحق ان تتحرك روسيا وان تجلب همم لها
المزيد من العداء من وراء استهدافها
لشخصيه كما يقيم وهو لا يراها شخصيه صف
اول رغم ان وزير داخليه ولكن يقول بانه لا
لروسيا اولوياته اخرى
طبعا يعني ضيف من روسي يقول ان كل اوكراني
الذي يحبها دولته ويؤيده هو وهو قومي انني
جميع الاوكرانيين وهو مقومين
وطبعا وهو يقول يعني ما يريده ولكن نحن
نعتقد ان تمزيق 31
بالنسبه لروسيا لانها اليوم همم غير قادر
همم القوات الاوكرانيه في ارض المعركه
ونحن همم يعني الجيش الاوكراني يعني قوي
جدا ولكن همم
انقسام اوكرانيا قد يفيدتها ولكن ضيفي همم
غير موافق همم السيد وداد باختصار لو سمحت
اه باختصار شديد نحن يعني اولا يعني انا
مستغرب
لغته العربيه ممتازه
لما تطلق الى الشعب الاوكراني ولا لقوميه
الشعوب الاوكراني ولا اي شيء يخص الشعب
الاوكراني
في حديثنا اليوم انما كما سمعنا
او المخابرات الاوكرانيه هي التي تولد
هذه القضيه او هذه الماساه الذي حدثت وهذا
شيء مريض لان عاده في هذه الاجواء يجب ان
تتولى الجيش
[موسيقى]
افندم التحقيقات
التحقيقات
المدني
لم نسمع بذلك اذا انا اعتقد لن نعرف
الحقيقه ابدا ما حدث وما ادى الى ذلك لكن
يتوقع
الى خلل هذه الطائره
يعني انا سمعت بها
كثيرا في صفقات منذ 10 سنوات حتى او ثمان
سنوات هذه الطائره
ليست همم محبوبه تماما من قبل اي احد ل-
همم
استغلالها
وفي اوروبا لاحدث
لان هذه الطائره يعني لوزاره الطوارئ هذه
الطائره غير مدنيه وهذا هو سبب لماذا
تطورت همم
يعني همم جهاز الامن الاوكراني احقيقات
هذا هو سبب رئيسي انها طائره غير مدنيه ان
الطائره العسكريه
وضحت الفكره انتهى توقيت هو الوقت دركنا
ولكن اكيد سيكون للنقاش بقيه شكرا جزيلا
لكما من موسكو تيمور دويدار الخبير في
قطاع الاعمال والعلاقات الدوليه ومن وابو
ظبيه
والاوكرانيه شكرا لكم